وزي ما انت شايف كلها بوادي د ميه ونقر
ميه ومش عارفين حتى نقضي حاجتنا مش عارفين
انا تسير القهوه من خانيونس الشرقيه من
بنسله احنا زعين لما قالوا لنا اطلعوا من
مناطقكم طلعنا وجينا هنا وعملنا النيلون
وطقي الخشبات وتمام تمام امبارح لما مطرت
الدنيا بدلت بهدلتنا يعني ما نمنا طول
الليل واللي بيفحر خندق واللي بيعمل بدود
واللي بذوق مسمار واللي انكسرت ع ريشته
والوضع ماساوي جدا جدا يعني ما حدش نام في
المنطقه حتى المنطقه هذ ما حدش مدور عليها
خالص ولا خيمه ولا خشبه ولا حاجه كل واحد
من جيبته بيصرف هذه خيمه مكونه من 13 نفر
تقريبا واحنا نا زي ما انت شايف شايف الصه
كيف والاطفال مش عارفين يمشوا ولا يتحركوا
وطول الليل مطر وما عرفنا يعني ننام ولا
نتحرك وتعال تفضل شوف الخيمه كيف طاحت
فينا ووقعت فينا وشوف مش عارفين نعمل ولا
حاجه شايف حالنا كيف شايف كانت الليله
الليله صعبه صعبه صعبه الخيمه نزلت على
الارض ما ضلش خيمه من المطر ماضل خيمه
وبعدين ما عندناش امكانيات احنا احنا يعني
ما عندناش الامكانيات اللي نقدر نعمل حاجه
كوويسه ننام بها يعني على قد حالنا
عملنا
ه